I have been dancing for about eighteen
years now and I worked with RuPaul's
Drag Races peppermint
I have travelled to China to work with
Angela Zayn Chris Wu Jackson Wang and
also the towel I have been dancing since
I could walk
I've worked with Lady Gaga matrix
L'Oreal uLTA Beauty dance and runway
shows in Las Vegas this challenge mehgan
stallion it is 28 times 10 so let's see
home girl do it always know if you don't
just on Matthews will be here this one's
cute and you actually move and like you
groove a little bit like it's a step in
the right direction
[Music]
she goes like a hitch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
because that's the thing about dance
y'all is no matter what we always
growing and sometimes the easiest dances
are the hardest dances any professional
dancer can tell you that this dance is
so high and there's really not too much
that I can say technically about it
other than there's a wave in there and
my biggest pet peeve is when the wave is
done wrong this is the proper way to do
a wave wrist elbow shoulder chest
shoulder elbow wrist open and then
connect them t-type helps you pick up
choreography pretty quickly
tick-tock helps you understand rhythm so
even just bouncing on the beat is
helping you understand timing and and
rhythm in music sweep floor sweep kick
ball change
[Music]
as dancers we are training our ears to
hear every single layer of the music so
that we can dance on the sounds and the
music and ultimately make it look like
our bodies are creating send sounds
[Music]
think about these dances that is that
they're very very very very very literal
so that makes it easier to remember like
heart pitter patter girl thank you major
point you're learning
tick-tock dance is the festival early
quick is to pick like a pinpoint mousse
I know she's gonna go because I said a
bar that part stood out to me i salute
[Music]
some rings is my favorite so far because
it is the most full out this dance is a
workout and to me I think it must
closely resembles the beginner Street
dries class than any of the other
dancers most of this dance is groups
like there's so many curves in here I
think it's a pony somewhere I've done
this stuff in almost every street dress
cause I have ever taken
[Music]
did I have any trouble learning any of
the steps the answer is yes we are not
perfect like we are always working on
ourselves that's the fun thing about
dances that you have to keep evolving
then you can't be stagnant and once you
do so it was difficult in that aspect
was a little minute we all move
differently we're all different people
we're all shaped different so
understanding how you move and feeling
confident and you know standing out in
your own way is a big thing and I think
tick tock is a really great place to
figure out what makes you you as a
dancer you see this buzzfeed you say
this that's you
[Music]